today we are doing two chapters that
have to do with Judaism
yeah we should always think when we're
looking at the textbook and why you know
where where were locating things why
they're doing this now you know after
we've looked at very briefly Native
American religions and traditionally
African religions have on their diaspora
into the American setting particularly
the Caribbean and then immigration the
American setting why are you looking at
Judaism you think why not just like jump
right into Protestant denominations that
have played a role in early colonial and
sure that is home because that Jesus guy
was Jewish yeah and so are all those
apostles and so are most of the early
Christians until it sort of spread out
so a lot of the Christian concepts
coming out of Judaism yeah some of the
things actually that Protestants
Protestant denominations took stands on
are going to have to do with like going
back to biblical practices so it makes
sense to look at it that way any other
reasons that come to mind what if we
think about like Native American
religions and these traditional African
religions and then Judaism is there
anything that they have in common
now nothing in terms of like you know
particularly deities or practices they
do have some some basic elements of
religion is there anything else what
they have in common what about time
they're all right Judaism the antedates
Christianity that's part of why it's
very helpful to know something about
Judaism to understand Christianity okay
yeah some of the basic ideas are you
know coming through that so it makes
sense to do that and then you notice the
chapters after that when he starts
talking about Christianity and decided
across to push
immediately is gonna start talking about
the Eastern Orthodox and Catholics
because there are older branches or
officiating
so we're working at this chronologically
so it makes sense to begin with with
Judaism what we're looking at at the
beginning is not quite the same as what
we would think about as Judaism today
because there's been a lot of growth and
transformation and arguments and splits
and things like that but have taken
place these are some basic ideas that
we're going to find in most religions
basic elements we can say and the
textbook is organized in part of the way
it should be around trying to explain
these the chapter that we're looking at
right now chapter 3 is trying to become
a thumbnail sketch about basic concepts
within Judaism chapter 4 is going to be
more historical and developmental so
they kind of play off of each other do
you have to do it that way no there's
there's a lot of ways to teach this
material but I think this is a
particularly good way to do it and he
starts out actually talking about this
notion of commandments and we associate
the notion of commandment the notion of
law or code we're going to talk about
that in just a moment and you know
there's a given number of them which you
know you can you can read about it and
he actually talks about the positive of
the negative ones
and where do you find these in the first
five books of both Christian and Jewish
Bible Genesis Exodus numbers Leviticus
and Deuteronomy those are those various
books of the law and you'll find a lot
of thou shalt through thou shalt not not
just the tension
but all the other ones and traditionally
this has been understood as as essential
to to what it meant to be a Jew to be a
to be somebody who would follow these
these Commandments at least as best as
you could some of them are you know kind
of tough to do some of them don't seem
particularly relevant you know if you
actually I'm going to read through these
these biblical books at one time or
another so those are the those of you
who do who have you know that there's a
lot of Commandments that probably don't
seem that relevant in every situation
like if your tent has leprosy here's
what you're supposed to do by that you
know sort of mold type of thing not
happening all that often right but some
of the commandments are really central
thou shalt not steal
that's a biggie right don't move hungry
murderers what do you know what do you
think that has to do with it don't cheat
essentially don't don't change the
meanings of of things and so this is all
part of Jewish life and you know we're
talking about several millennia of
reflection on just what does this stuff
actually mean for us in individual life
so he talks about worth of praxis and or
that practice means right living it's
not just north of doxy which means right
believe it but worth of praxis Judaism
is a lived religion the next things that
he talks about have to do with belief
and that text and then community
he begins talking about the shame which
is this passage from Deuteronomy here o
Israel the Lord is our God Lord is one
and thou shalt love the Lord thy God
with all thy heart and all they saw all
they might and it goes on from there
what is this this is an expression of
central expression of belief that is
normative for for Jews you've got
radical monotheism but there's one
element God is one
that was a pretty radical thing to say
back in ancient times because most
systems were polytheistic all of their
neighbors were polytheistic now you know
there's historical questions of did they
really start out being pure monotheists
or is that something that develops over
time at the very least you can say
that's there they were they were
connected with one day Yahweh and then
you know over time that becomes you know
very exclusive he also talks about text
and I've already mentioned Torah
his first five books of the Bible that
are considered to be norm normative so
I'm going to ask about who's read all
five who's read at least parts of the
book of Exodus who's read parts of the
book of Genesis you should probably take
a look at these oh you know maybe over
the weekend see what what sort of stuff
is in there is it all legal code those
of you who have read these what else is
in there yeah there's a lot of narrative
yeah and that narrative is understood as
being centrally important we're going to
look at this a bit more in the next
chapter what else what but in Genesis
what what sort of things are happening
there if they Adam and Eve story right
is that just about some guy and some
girl in the garden and maybe an apple
and a snake or you know could be a
quince nobody's actually sure what kind
of fruit it is some scholars think it's
a quince or is it supposed to teach you
something
this will set some sort of deeper
meaning that wins a quince is in the
apple and pear family and it's got this
wonderful smell to it almost like sweet
turns and this is a complete digression
by the way it's got a very astringent
taste tip
even when it's right so you generally
have to be careful in how you how you
cook it but but it's it smells wonderful
if you cook it right it tastes water
normally that really I mean if you're a
hardcore I suppose you could waste it
groans I thought I'd know about it
I'm gonna give you my daughter one time
when she was little for giving her one
just to see you know how she screw up
your face away
I gave it's nice we just know what CNN
the story it's some sort of fruit the
story is about the human condition right
and you know what was the next story
that follows after that the first murder
yeah jealousy anger these are dealing
with very fundamental human conditions
and so the story and the legal code they
kind of go hand in hand they're supposed
to connect up with each other and
illuminate each other there's other
texts that play an important role that
he talks about you might hear talk about
Tom Woods and Tomlin is there's this
vast proliferation of texts this is just
I brought in a big book in a little book
sort of props and that was the time when
I'm gonna bring up the big book for you
this is when he talks about the mission
of this is the mission of this was
supposed to be passed down orally from
the time of Moses and then only later I
was written down and it forms part of
the Talmud it's understood as being the
oral part of the law and if you read
through it it's a lot of discussions
between people about what do the what do
the laws actually mean you could you
know you can get a sense of just how
easy is this way
by looking at them oh oh oh I should
pass it around if you can take a look at
it you want to it's pretty dry stuff
until you till you get into it along
with the the Mishnah in the homeland you
have tomorrow which is just commentary
anything well what does this mean what
is this about
yeah so it's not just a Torah that's
considered to be normative it's also the
pom what this this reflection on what
the laws mean about what it means to be
a follower of the commandments what else
talks about community and you know here
we're thinking about Israel itself yeah
this is one of those words that mean
more than one thing Hampton if I say
Israel what pops to your head
immediately what's the first thing that
comes to mind
oh so yeah that wasn't what I was
expecting but that's good so already
you're thinking in terms of several
millennia ago when there actually were
twelve tribes ten of them got got
destroyed by the Assyrians and got
scattered it's only two of them survived
in Judah what else do you think about
what's for the rest of you what's the
first thing that comes to mind say
Israel yeah there's there's an actual
portion of land that at one time the
people that we you know at that time
we're called the Hebrews also the
Israelites the ones in the South were
called the Jews the Judean because
they're from Judea and actually that
term comes to cover the rest of them
they lived there that was considered to
be in the promised land and there's all
sorts of discussions about what you know
what exactly that means
Israel was for awhile a major player in
the Middle East Iraq you know under
Kings like David and Solomon had trade
routes extending all the way to here to
Ethiopia then it disappeared for a long
time it became part of the Roman
province of Palestine and it's only in
recent years that we can speak of a
state of Israel again
where you know what else would be it
also means the people the Jewish people
themselves so it's it's not a term that
only refers to one things say Israel
lives partly in Israel and partly in New
York and partly in Baghdad and partly in
where every policy like the men using
the term there's really two different
ways actually to protect to connected
things what else do you have to talk
about in terms of community what a
community is always yeah we'll get to
rich alone the medicine I'll say rituals
yeah yes so the leadership in the Jewish
community your book gives you two
important purpose originally
you would have Kings you know when when
Israel was still a kingdom and they
played an important role when you had
prophets and they often played an
important role sometimes they got you
know thrown into Wow bulls are in things
like that they weren't always on the
right side of the king and then you also
have the priests in the temple but the
temple was destroyed a long time ago
there's a little portion of it left in
Israel
yeah and who became the people who
exercised authority yeah
who's your book talk about I think about
Jewish communities today yeah this is an
important transformation originally
rabbi means teacher so you'll actually
see in the Gospels Jesus being referred
to by some people addressing him as
rabbi meaning teacher if you weren't
worshipping in the temple and most Jews
could you know by the time that we're
looking at the first century Common Era
where would Jews be they'd be scattered
all over the place
where would they go to worship that not
the temple there was actually by the way
more than one temple they discovered
like you know another temple like
elephantine and in Egypt which was used
by Jewish mercenaries it's very far down
the Nile a whole different conversation
there but that's not most people at that
time go to synagogues and synagogues
that means a place where you gather
people together it's coming from Greek
and you know the Torah would be read and
people would comment on it eventually
rabbis when when the temple is no longer
there come to take on a greater and
greater role your book talks about some
of the transformations that actually
take place in America are there any
other people who exercise important
authority within Jewish communities
traditional Jewish communities what is
your book to talk about they bring up on
page 34 we cancel or cousin Cantor is a
person who sings right so is this like
you know the pop stars come with happy
music
it's the next big hit so you give them
some authority like we do a celebrity
not exactly that right this is ritual
singing lesson it's a part of the
service yeah and if you don't ever ran
by the Saint the Cantor is somebody who
actually knows the sort of order of
ritual and they end up taking out an
important role as well particularly in
the absence of rabbis in early America
so they end up assuming
all these things sort of reinforce each
other what really ties it together is
that your book talks about his ways of
punctuating time with with ritual so how
many different ways would we look at
that do that
there's the year right the yearly cycle
so we're going to talk about some of the
holidays in just a minute those would be
examples yeah what else what are what
are other ways people mark time that are
meaningful that are tied into the
rituals let's think about some secular
rituals when were you allowed to get
your driver's license your real driver's
license not the learner's permit 17
where's the 17
really wow I didn't know about this
managers yeah make you wait that long
when everyone else gets to do when
they're 16 that's a coming-of-age right
another sort of coming-of-age things you
guys will be experiencing anywhere from
1 to 3 years from now would be walking
across the stage down there in the you
know by the Student Center in ceremonial
garb cap and gown it'll be pretty hot
most likely and kind of odd boring
ceremony and somebody may skip it but
that's that's a secular ritual right
what is it marking it's marking a
transition from being a student to to
adult life as an educated person so
we've got here we've also got the
rituals that that have to do with a
person's life so we have two different
dimensions and this holds for a lot of
different
religions there are two important
dimensions one is cyclical and one you
can think of this is linear so when
we're thinking about cyclical ones let's
get rid of some of this stuff the big
cycle of the year where you output
January on top or the bottom so I've
heard to figure out exactly there's it's
arbitrary isn't how we divide up time
let's uh let's put it up here so here's
here's December and here's January we're
using our normal calendar months are
secular months where there's two
different ways in which time is is
parsed out one is that every week I know
I'm not gonna get like you know 51 did
you in here the way in octave but you
get the idea what happens we have seven
days in a week because we've adopted
this this 17 way of reckoning things not
everybody has that why does that matter
particularly for Jewish life
what happens every seven days yeah
exactly the Sabbath means seven thing
you're gonna say the same thing right
and Jewish observance of the Sabbath is
one of the central elements orthopraxy
you know doing the religion rather than
just believing you notice it's one of
the 10 10 commandments the Decalogue
yeah there's supposed to be no work done
which which includes things like cooking
so you know they'll set aside food
there's a whole bunch of different rules
if you're really hardcore about this
they'd have to do with what you're
allowed to do to do but the idea is that
it's supposed to be a day of being bored
exactly yes yeah yeah there's even sort
of any you know big example up in the
sky for it even God took a break on the
seventh day so everybody should take a
break and it's also tied in with years
you know they're supposed to be foul
periods
7 times 7 you have a jubilee there's a
lot involved there that your book
doesn't talk about then there's holidays
and I'm just going to sort of could have
been hurt handily because I'm not gonna
try to be very exact at certain points
of the year where important things are
going on and he talks about just a few
of these he talks about Passover or poss
reward for which by the way means Easter
it's really hostile from because Easter
for Christians was actually you know at
the time of Passover and the Passover is
to celebrate the liberation in Exodus
and there's food that's supposed to be
eaten to remind them what took place
there's you know a narrative that goes
along with it to remind them of their
religious identity he talks about Rosh
Hashanah which is the beginning of the
High Holy Days and
hi holy days are a time in part for
reconsidering one's life for putting
things into perspective Yom Kippur is
this this Day of Atonement atonement is
when you try to make up for the things
that you've really screwed up take stock
of it and a lot of New Year's rituals by
the way in a lot of cultures are not
these you know sort of Bacchanalia of
going out and getting getting drunk and
maybe hooking up or something like that
they're actually more sober times of
getting together and being kind of quiet
and thinking about how do I unscrew up
my life my screwed up life because you
know by the time that you live a while
generally your life is finished
clean up in certain respects yeah so a
lot of times New Year's rituals are tied
in with them another important holiday
is so good are the feast of booths and
they'll be is also sometimes called the
Feast of Tabernacles of tabernacle means
a tent and so they'll be attentive
rekted and they'll be not actually like
lives in the tents the whole time
because I mean imagine doing that here
you know with the weather the way it is
here but if these they'll put it they'll
put something up there and spend some
time in it and what is it commemorating
the time you spent out there you know
wilderness wandering pyramid has to do
with what took place in the book of
Esther one of the first sort of imperial
deliverance stories you could say if you
haven't read the book of Esther you got
read it's really funny reading in a lot
of respects it's sort of like an
adventure story this is this girl
there's a villain who tries to you know
organize a mass killing of all the Jews
across the entire Persian Empire and
they are able to thwart him and that's a
commemoration of that and then finally
they talk about Hanukkah and Hanukkah is
changed its its orientation a bit and in
recent times and especially in America
what is it originally a commemoration of
does anyone know whether the eight
candles
no one's familiar with that it's a
commemoration of a event that supposed
to have taken place during these wars
that the Jews were fighting under the
Maccabees you find this discussed in the
books of the Maccabees which are not
part of the Jewish canon but are part of
the the Orthodox and Roman Catholic
Canon of Scripture yeah the the the Jews
finally kicked these Greeks out and
there's a whole big story about why that
was important and the Greeks have
desecrated the temple and the temple was
a very important holy place so one thing
that they needed to do was to actually
light the lights yeah you know nowadays
we have electricity what do they use
that very good yeah it wasn't just
torches like you see in the movies it
was oil because oil is actually reliable
you know and will burn for a while and
so you would keep a supply of oil on ham
they only have enough for one day and
they needed enough for eight days and
we'll never ran out and that's what the
whole thing is a commemoration of what
does it can turn into now because of the
time of the year Hanukkah falls right
around here usually what else usually
falls right around here for a lot of
people in our culture yeah exactly so
you can get yourself a Hanukkah tree
that's you know decorated and blue and
white and he even brings up Hanukah
carrier uncle max the Chanukah man which
is you know pure pure fabrication is
supposed to be sort of like an
equivalent to Santa Claus and there's a
locket I mean you I'll just just google
it you'll find a lot of comparisons
Christmas laughing it's at the detriment
of Hanukkah because it wasn't originally
designed to be you knew there was
Christmas and Chucky a massive
gift-giving holiday I think Christmas is
a bit more successful in that respect
and it's transformation but all these
are ways in which a time is made sacred
there's one other element that I sort of
skipped over that would fit into this
and also in belief and practice and math
is having to do with food this is
something very distinctive to finally
Jewish culture but Jewish religion why
does food there are their ritual laws
about what can be eaten on Canada data
and this has actually produced a lot of
great food because if you can't use
certain ingredients and kind of like the
taste of those ingredients have you got
to find substitutes or you got to work
with what you've got and make it turn
out an interesting ways these are what
we call you know often the the kosher
laws and they're coming from mostly
stuff in Italy it says in Leviticus this
stuff in Genesis as well the forbidding
eating blood is actually coming from the
Noah's story
what is the life and your book talks
about three main elements to this of
waiting pork and shellfish and a number
of other animals the Bible by the way
would divide the animals up a little bit
differently than we do that's why it's
sometimes this is a digression but you
know when people say well what about
Catholics and Glanton and not eating
fish why are they allowed just not
eating meat rather but what if fish's
meat why are they allowed to do that
because if you look at the biblical
stories they classified animals into the
birds of the air right the fish of the
sea the herd animals of the land and
then creeping things yeah and you were
supposed to eat creeping things
no snakes or scorpions there were some
things like you could eat certain you
know sort of locusts which people do in
the Middle East and birds of the area
you you know you couldn't heat for
example birds of prey when it came to
the animals of the land there's there's
rules you know it has to both chew the
cud and have cloven hooves so that rules
out for example pigs right because what
a pigs feet
there's a trick question anything but
here they're one of the most numerous
creatures on earth they're like us
they'll leave Billy any stuff we put in
front of them so that's not the cut
right split hooves means there's there's
some animals that that would be ruled
out that do eat grass you think of any
any animals that don't have split hooves
I don't know I don't know enough about
camels I was thinking horses but you
know but those are those are rules
another major important thing and this
comes from a law saying you shall not
boil a calf in its mother's milk which
probably had to do some Canaanite
rituals it was interpreted as don't mix
meat and dairy so you couldn't for it
could not have a kosher sausage pizza
for example it would be impossible and
actually the dishes that you you cook
with meat and dairy have to be kept
separate from each others this is part
of kosher kitchens and kosher
observances the slaughter at the end
this has to be done in a certain way so
it's to remove all of a blood so when
you see kosher meat what it's saying is
that it's been slaughtered in accordance
with these guidelines and if you're an
observant Jew you would want to keep
kosher this is actually going to be a
dividing line when we go to later on you
look at say the form Judaism as opposed
to Orthodox Judaism that would be one
big dividing line between them the
reformed Jews celebrated one of their
first
togethers by having shrimp which would
be ruled out by the kosher laws so
that's all the stuff in Chapter three in
a very whirlwind tour